Google Bart sucks or at least that seems
to be the general opinion hitting on
board it definitely seems to be the
popular thing Twitter is literally
filled with tweets Mockingbird for its
failures and it's no wonder why from
resorting to Bing to get the answer to
recommending Edge over chrome Bard has
made quite a few hilarious blunders but
I don't think this is the real problem I
mean there's plenty of compilations of
chat GPT making mistakes as well from
thinking that inches is a unit of mass
to not knowing how to multiply negative
numbers chatgpt is prone to making a
bunch of mistakes as well but what's
different between the two is how people
respond to the same mistakes when Bard
messes up people tend to laugh at it and
the attitude seems to carry a negative
connotation if I were Sam Altman or
satinadella I would be feeling very
concerned right now when chat gbt messes
up however it tends to just be a meme
it's the classic case of people tend to
laugh with Chachi PT while they laugh at
bard of course this is very much
anecdotal but I think there's more to it
than just that take a look at adoption
rates for example Bard was able to reach
30 million users within one month of
launch which sounds great Until you
realize that Chachi PT was able to reach
100 million users within just 2 months
and yes I do know that the board
launched with a waiting list but I don't
think that really made a difference just
take a look at Google's own Trends data
this becomes exponentially worse when
you consider that touch EBT came from
open AI a no-name company that most
people have never heard of while Bard
literally came directly from Google
likely the most ubiquitous internet
company in the world clearly there seems
to be a general hesitance when it comes
to even drawing board I mean just think
about this people are literally willing
to go out of their way to use a bing and
Edge to use chat gbt instead of just
using Google and Chrome and I don't
think this has anything to do with how
good or bad board actually is I mean you
can easily make a case for Bard being
better for starters it has a live access
to the internet it integrates with
Google and the UI is arguably far better
yet no one seems to care and I think
this has more to do with the Google
brand as opposed to Google board so join
me as we examine the deterioration of
the Google brand and why Bard is at a
major disadvantage regardless of how
good it really is
foreign
to understand why Bard is how should I
say it flopping by all accounts we have
to take a look at why other Google
products did so well to begin with
looking back it's actually been quite a
while listen to Google hit a home run
Google's Glory Days were really back in
the 2000s when they were launching
bangers left and right they had Android
in 2008 Chrome also in 2008 YouTube in
2005 Google Maps also in 2005 and Gmail
in 2004. clearly they were killing it
but by all accounts they shouldn't have
been Gmail came out in an era when Yahoo
mail and Hotmail had already won over
the market and a contrary to popular
belief YouTube is not the OG video
sharing platform both the Vimeo and
Dailymotion actually came out before
YouTube and as for Chrome well Chrome
came out during a time when Internet
Explorer was ubiquitous so Google should
have had no chance yet they were able to
rise above the big tech companies of the
era Microsoft and Yahoo so what gave
Google The Edge well one of the biggest
factors that propelled to Google forward
was the fact that they were the scrappy
startup trying to take on these big tech
companies and much of Google's success
actually didn't have to do with how good
Google's products were and more to do
with how much people hated Microsoft
this might be hard to imagine and given
that Microsoft has largely faded into
the background but back in the early
2000s Microsoft was the most highly
contested company in the world there was
literally a Supreme Court case regarding
whether Microsoft should be broken up
into two different companies Microsoft
would barely escape this fate to buy the
Skin of Their Teeth but the same could
not be said about public perception the
fact that Microsoft was able to
monopolize the computer space and get
away with it made people outraged this
was one of the main selling factors of
Firefox the idea was that people would
be more willing to support an open
source project as opposed to a big Tech
offering and they were right up until
Chrome came out Firefox was rapidly
eating into internet Explorer's market
share peaking at over 30 something else
to note is that virtually all of
Google's most successful products were
copycat products a search engine not new
an email not new a browser not new and
as for the Google office suite I mean do
I even have to say anything now Google
did make these spaces better with their
offerings Google search made it easier
to find things Gmail gave more storage
Chrome was way more reliable and
collaboration with the Google office was
light years ahead of Microsoft Office
but wait a minute isn't Google trying to
do the same thing with the Bard sure
they copy pasted chat GPT but they're
trying to make it better in terms of UI
live info and better integration right
well yeah but people aren't impressed at
giving Google's resources the bottom
line is that people used to resonate
with Google slogan of don't be evil
during a time when people felt that big
tag and especially Microsoft was evil
this perception hasn't changed all that
much over the years but Google's
position within the totem pole has they
are now the quote-unquote evil big tech
company and the people are just
naturally inclined to embrace the
underdog which in this case is chatgpt
hearing all this you might be inclined
to believe that the deterioration of
Google's brand is more of a recent Trend
but that's not the case in fact Google
has been fighting this uphill battle for
over a decade at this point and they've
actually been losing for quite some time
the first example of this trend dates
back to 2011 with Google plus if you're
not familiar with Google plus it was
basically Google's attempt at creating a
social media platform and taking on
Facebook but it ended up flopping
massively why well for starters 2011 was
clearly not too late to launch a social
media platform as we have seen massively
successful platforms being launched way
after many reports like to claim that it
was Google Plus lack of distinguishing
factors and lackluster UI that led to
its eventual failure but really the
number one factor that destroyed Google
Plus was the fact that Google was
pushing it down people's throats they
figured that since they already had a
bunch of users they no longer had to
convince these users based on the Merit
of their platform instead it they could
just force their existing YouTube users
to become Google Plus users as well and
with that Google made it required to
have a Google Plus account to make
comments on YouTube this ended up being
one of the most controversial decisions
of all time not only did millions of
YouTube users rise up against Google but
even a co-founder of YouTube rose up
jayward Karim after eight years of not
posting anything on his YouTube account
he would post why the F do I need a
Google Plus account to comment on a
video after taking all this heat Google
would of course roll back the Google
Plus integration with YouTube but by
this point the reputation of Google Plus
was already toast for the first time
people felt that Google had a big comma
the villain bundling Google Plus and
with YouTube was very much a Microsoft
move moreover Google was by no means the
underdog within the social media scene
you had Instagram and Snapchat and
WhatsApp and even Facebook who were all
much younger than Google but it wasn't
just younger companies that Google was
losing to either Google was also very
much losing to established companies as
well likely the best example is Google
meet which was trying to take on Skype
and WebEx again Google me didn't exactly
flop just because it was late to the
game just think about how big of an
opportunity they had with the pandemic
but no one chose Google meet everyone
chose Zoom or teams the reason being
that Google made it really didn't add
anything to the video conferencing space
other than the fact that it was from
Google Google me that just felt like a
product that was meant to expand
Google's reach and control as opposed to
something that really improved via
conferencing if anything it made a video
conferencing worse as it was
browser-based which came along with a
bunch of shortcomings and those are just
two examples some other massive flops
from Google over the past decade include
Google Buzz Google Tango Google
Daydreamer Google allo Google trips and
Google stadia just to name a few so as
you can see Google has struggled to
launch a new product for quite some time
now both against startups and establish
Giants but it gets even worse worse
not only has Google struggled to launch
new successful products but they have
also been putting off existing users by
making a slew of controversial decisions
for example
the dislike button despite the community
being largely against it similarly more
and the more Google search results seem
to be dominated by ads of course these
aren't groundbreaking developments but
each and every one of these choices make
users just a little bit more frustrated
with Google also we can't talk about
Google shortfalls without talking about
their privacy and data collection
concerns to be honest I think most
people have simply come to accept that
less privacy is simply how the modern
world works but that doesn't mean that
people are exactly happy with Google and
Facebook which brings us into the launch
of Google bard just by its initial
response you can tell that people are
predispositioned to find it unappealing
this isn't to say that Google will
necessarily shut down Bard in fact you
can bet that that's the last thing
they'll do as they try to make it in the
AI space but this doesn't exactly mean
that Bard will be successful sure a good
number of people will always use it just
because of how popular Google is as a
company but Google will have a pretty
tough time making Bard the dominant AI
language model instead it's likely that
board will end up like a bang and Edge
it didn't matter how good these products
were or what incentives they offered
Edge has been faster than Chrome for
years and Bing has literally been paying
users to use it but despite this
everyone continued to use Chrome and
Google and treated Edge and Bing as
second tier products and judging by
public perception it seemed that a very
similar fate is up ahead not just for
Bard but any consumer oriented part that
Google launches in the imminent future
likely the only way to combat this
perception is time back in the late
2000s Microsoft was faced with the same
dilemma everything they launched flopped
regardless of how good it was whether
that's the Zune or the Windows Phone the
way that Microsoft overcame this dilemma
was stepping out of the spotlight
focusing on the Enterprise business and
letting people find a new Microsoft hate
on which were Google and Facebook and
suddenly people are willing to give
Microsoft a chance again so the answer
for Google may be to also step back and
focus on their Enterprise Cloud business
and let people find a new Google to hate
on this would give Google the best shot
of success in the consumer space because
the truth with the bar is that it
doesn't matter how good it is because
people have already made up their minds
about Bard and that's why Google bard
doesn't stand a chance even if it's
better than Chachi BT things aren't
super Rosy at open AI either as they're
very much going through a funding crisis
check out this video to learn more but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one
thank you